all right one one of the realities
that's still kind of hanging in the
atmosphere as we look toward
the regular season the question of what
happens
if someone tests positive for the
coronavirus even if the person is
asymptomatic the belief is going to be
shut down because they can spread it to
other people close quarters on the field
etc
so you need to be ready you need to have
your roster properly configured
and bruce arians the buccaneers head
coach
was recently on chris long's green light
podcast
and long asked him about the possibility
of having a quarterback
who is quarantined in the event of an
outbreak
on the team here's bruce arians
discussing that possibility
that's one of the things i've been
pondering in the last two or three weeks
as we as we set the protocols
uh and from what i'm understanding is if
you test positive you're quarantined for
two weeks
now that if you have no symptoms
i don't know what that means yeah is it
is it a false one is it
i mean uh so i don't there's so much to
to learn and
and still explore with this thing but
i've thought about
keeping the third quarterback on the
roster out of the room
you know we have two guys that have been
in our system
really sharp so i might have to
quarantine a quarterback just in case of
a quarantine
that's bruce aries with chris long and
i'll just say this
and this is an example of the crap that
i have to deal with on a daily basis
because it really is amazing i've heard
people refer to social media as this
bastion of left-wing ideals trust me
put anything up there that anyone could
remotely characterize as left wing or
radical and you get attacked
by the other end of the spectrum
relentlessly and i floated the concept a
few weeks ago
of keeping a quarterback away from the
team in the event that your quarterback
room
gets infected by the coronavirus and you
need somebody who is clean
keep one guy away from the roster have
him ready to go people went nuts
people went nuts oh this is extreme oh
you're rooting against football oh why
do you hate football it's like
folks if your quarterbacks on the roster
both test positive
you're screwed if you don't have anybody
else ready to go you got to be thinking
about things like this
you got to have people stashed somewhere
and away from society so you know
they're clean
in the event your quarterback position
gets decimated by this
you can go next man up everywhere else
if you don't have any quarterbacks you
got no chance chris
no no chance i mean i i think it's a
very real thought
and possibility that bruce arians is
talking about i mean
uh of course i'm worried about all
positions you know
and again like we've talked about i do
think this is something that
the nfl has to continue to talk about
and figure out
because i think they got to give these
teams a little bit more wiggle room with
the roster this year
there has to be you know a certain set
of guidelines for
2020 football in the colburn 19 era
where they expand
rosters or expand expand the practice
squad
and maybe they can have those guys
quarantined off i don't know how they're
gonna do it
um i will say this the other thing that
just pops into my head mike about like
the quarterback situation too
i mean really weird too you're gonna
have a guy
you know sanctioned off from the rest of
the football team uh
at the quarterback position where we
know okay yeah he'll probably get to be
able to get in the zoom meetings and
things like that but man
i mean what if okay two of your
quarterbacks they get covered 19. now
this third guy he's been at home for
four weeks
just paying attention to the video video
meetings and things like that hasn't you
know practiced with the team and do
all of that i mean that's where i just
look at it and go whoa
if we get to that point right there this
season's gonna be like
you know more insanely crazy than i than
i expected it to be
still better than having no quarterback
at all who's able to play
because he's negative for the
coronavirus and that's part of this
great disconnect we talked about this
earlier in the week the idea that
extreme measures are being put in place
for facilities
to keep guys six feet apart to ensure
that there is
no spread of the coronavirus no meetings
indoors virtual meetings even during
football season
wherever they can be done more than 20
do it outside
all of the things to keep guys from
getting each other sick and then
once per week you get out there in a
scrum of 11 on 11 with
guys pressed up against each other
sweating and bleeding and spitting in
each other's faces and
it's just a strange dichotomy chris of
the way the world is going to be
but i think the idea is keep these guys
as clean as possible
so when you do put them on the field you
have some degree of confidence
that they're not carrying the virus but
when you look at the number of players
in the league the number of players on
the rosters i think that
may be a little bit optimistic and again
in saying that
the whole thing is optimistic why do you
not want football season to happen it's
like i want football season to happen i
just want people
who are paid to be thinking through
these issues to be thinking through the
issues and have a plan in place so that
we do have a season so that when there's
a group of games that is due to be
played on a given sunday
you don't start scratching off three of
them because
one of the teams doesn't have enough
healthy guys or enough guys who are
negative for the corona fires that's
what's going to make it even crazier
chris
think about how mad guys are going to be
they test positive
and they're perfectly fine but they
can't play
yeah i i i know i mean i i i look at
this whole situation and think maybe
we're being way too optimistic
you know that's again mike why i really
wish they would like take a poll
a secret vote with players whatever it
may be
to get a gauge of like hey
you know if kobit 19 does break out in
your locker room
you know are you comfortable still
playing and being around teammates or
you know playing against another team
that has a few players that have it
i think those are like real tough
conversations that have to start
happening
because mike if we get to week four and
we're already seeing right now
in states and things that you know the
social distancing has stopped the
numbers are starting to pick up
so here we are in week four in the nfl
what are we gonna do if we got like
eight teams that got like half their
team
is infected with cove at 19. i mean
although i don't know how we can so
we're gonna stop the season for a few
weeks again and then
start it up and then it's gonna happen
again and we're gonna stop
like to me at some point there just
needs to be the flatline
question of hey nfl
team a if you guys get kobit 19
are you guys going to be cool with just
yes it's in your building
and you might you can go home or maybe
you get sanctioned off to some special
hotel after the facility or whatever it
may be
but i do think they're going to have to
start having those conversations to see
where players are at
you know if that scenario does happen am
i crazy to say that players are no
you aren't crazy to say that because
you're right most of these guys are
between the ages of 21 and 27.
they don't care here's the problem
though the national football league
players association is led by demoria
smith has already made it clear
at least it was clear in a video
conference that was held before the
draft
they aren't going to do anything that is
going to jeopardize the health and
welfare of the community
so you're not going to allow this virus
to run
rampant in a facility or rampant through
the league
kind of do the sweden approach to the
nfl
and then all these guys go home at night
they're out in the community they have
days off they take it home to their
families
and it gets passed around that way the
nfl pa is not going to go for that
also also there are guys
in the nfl coaches and players
who have risk factors that will set them
up for a severe outcome
so while most of these guys and that
that's kind of like what mike gundy the
oklahoma st
estate coach first said when this all
came up oh my guys are young and healthy
they'll be fine
well you know what there are plenty of
guys who play in the nfl based upon the
body type necessary for their position
who are morbidly obese
what happens to them you know they say
well hey if you have diabetes you want
to stay away from coronavirus there's a
lot of people don't know they're
diabetic
remember jay cutler the year that he was
sick and
right and he was couldn't hold on
couldn't keep on weight nobody knew what
was wrong with him and how long did it
take the broncos doctors to figure out
maybe we should have a blood test and
see if he's diabetic
so patrick peterson same thing and
plenty of people yeah there's
they haven't they don't know they have
it that's a hell of a way to find out
you have it
and you got coaches who are older bill
belichick 68
pete carroll's pushing 70. you got
assistant coach you got tom
moore i i look so so i understand what
you're saying chris this is one of those
cases where
the grown-ups in the room need to be
willing to speak the hard truths to the
23-year-old chris sims out there
who's saying screw this i want to play
football hey that's a false positive i'm
fine test me again
test me again throwing a chair through
the window test me again
you're gonna have to be able to get
these guys under control and say this is
not the way it's gonna be
and that's where the union and the
league need to make sure they have
clear understandable rules for
everything and the one thing that
concerns me about that when the nfl
issued the memo over the weekend with
the initial protocol for facilities and
stadiums and
tier one access to restricted areas tier
two tier three
all of these things the nflpa sent out a
text message to all the players saying
we didn't agree to any of this
so they got to get on the same page and
there's a lot of crap to work out
and i've been saying this for three
months back when oh you don't want a
football season to happen oh you're
oh you're it's fear porn no there's a
lot of crap to deal with folks and i
hope to god that if they want to have a
football season
they're going to work this stuff out all
of these issues that chris and i are
just kind of haphazardly throwing out
there
these are real concerns somebody's got
to be writing them all down
and i remember having a sense back in
late march
the problem is every question you
answer spawns five more questions
that you have to answer which leads to
five more questions
each and it mushrooms out of control
no doubt i mean you're just sitting here
talking about it i flushed a few things
out and my
little rant about you know you're right
there's just so many contingency plans
whether it's quarterbacks extra guys on
the roster
hey this coach got it but none of the
other coaches have it i mean
that's why uh yes i feel like the nfl
and nfl pa are lagging a little bit in
their conversations that's why i bring
it up
and i just feel like some things need to
get hashed out into a little bit more of
a further
detail if we're really truly gonna i'm
gonna make this happen here in 2020.
on march 11 rudy gobert nba player with
utah jazz test positive
and it shut the nba down positive tests
will not shut down the nfl but i'll tell
you this as we go to break
if one person dies in and around the nfl
it's done it's over until 2021 at the
earliest
that and look you don't want anybody
dying but i'm just saying from the
standpoint of the nfl
how do you justify proceeding if you've
got people
who ultimately expire and succumb to the
covet 19
illness hi i'm mike tarico and thanks
for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports